[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today James is
with us James is in Orlando hi James how
are you
hey how you doing thank you so much for
having me on Sherman what's up
so I'm having trouble getting to pay off
my debt I've tried many different things
make budget apps different things like
that and I've just come to the
realization over the past few days
actually that I'm just not I I lack the
discipline and it really needed to stop
living paycheck to paycheck and the
saddest part is I have a really good
salary what's your really good salary
um I make 170. oh that's impressive okay
how much of that do you have sir
uh collectively I have 27 27 28 000 what
kind of woke me up on this is I ignored
my debt for years
um and then one of my both of my credit
cards were canceled and I settled one of
them and that was fine and then the
other one I honestly completely forgot
about until a few days ago when I
received a I was served because they're
suing me for the debt and that kind of
woke me up where I said I need to stop
pushing things I think I kept pushing
things forever because I said well you
know I have a good amount of money
coming and you know my next paycheck and
I'll deal with it then but how long
you've been making 170 James
just for about six months what were you
making before that
um I was making I I was out of work for
about a year during covid which really
hit me hard and so during that I was
doing Uber and making you know about 20
000 a year before that I was making 90.
what do you do
I work in politics
okay be Consulting okay so is that
cyclical does that go away in another
nine months
no um I I this will be my salary at
least for the next few years
um I don't anticipate a changing or
changing jobs be some things to keep in
mind too I have to have two places to
live because my job commutes a lot
between here in Orlando and in New York
City some of my uh colleagues that I
work with do hotels
um but most people just end up having
two places of residence so do you have
we currently have two places of
residence
yes and how much is the New York
apartment
the New York apartment is
um two thousand how much is the Orlando
Department
um 1200
um but my my girlfriend uh and I split
it so okay so so this is uh sorry the
1200 is what I pay in my split
okay so this is forty thousand dollars
so so basically you've been spending
somewhere
all of your money for the last six
months which is 85 000 it's other than
some rent is unaccounted for
yeah so you're spending your money James
so it's a combination of me living
beyond my means yeah and also yeah it's
a combination of that but also there's
some key different things that I just
don't have that I think so for instance
I don't have a car I do need to get a
car and instead of because you know I've
been my credit I've been worried about
where is eighty thousand dollars gone in
six months it's starting to sound like
Congress
it's me it's me it's I've been renting
cars a lot um instead of buying I my
girlfriend's out of work so I've been
covering a lot of her expenses and then
I'm living beyond so the whole thing I'm
splitting the rent was bull crap
yeah
she does that but beyond that but beyond
that I've been covering a lot of things
so it's I definitely need to get my
stuff together the other thing to keep
okay here's what I do in these
situations and I I have to set a new set
of things instead of going I'm
I I'm just not good at this I've not got
any discipline I and you keep naming off
all these things that you are that you
actually aren't it's just what you do
um that's not your actual identity uh so
what I decided a year a few years ago I
had the blessing of going completely
bankrupt and losing everything so I
didn't have a choice
I was in an extreme situation the only
way I could eat
would was to behave
the only way my children had a warm home
was to behave I didn't have a choice and
so what I've done with folks like you
over the years is I want you to put
yourself mentally in a space as if you
don't have a choice let's just pretend
this okay let's pretend that you go to
the doctor this afternoon and he says
you need 27 000 by Christmas
or you're gonna die
all of a sudden James you would be a
person of discipline
all of a sudden your budget would be
perfect all of a sudden your stupid
decisions would go away because you
would have one goal I want to live I
want twenty seven thousand dollars by
December and suddenly all of this bull
crap that's running around in your head
would become laser focused and you'd be
going twenty seven thousand dollars
James got one goal stay alive get twenty
seven thousand dollars no other goal
matters no other crap matters my
colleagues have two apartments who gives
a crap what your colleagues do you are a
broke guy making 170 you gotta change
some crap
really this has got you gotta you gotta
get up in your face man get up in your
own Grill and go that's enough I've had
it I am this is crazy I'm ashamed I'm
disgusted with how this looks and how
this feels because that's what you've
been telling me
and I I'm so disgusted that I'm gonna
change it
and if you get sick and tired of being
sick and tired James that's when you
change your life
yeah because you you know stupid people
don't make 170 Grand a year
they don't they don't even get hired
okay you couldn't even have gotten the
job if you were stupid so you're not
stupid
but buddy you've been doing some stupid
stuff hadn't you
yeah so stop it for real
just pretend you need twenty seven
thousand dollars by Christmas or you're
gonna die
and all of a sudden I'm not renting any
cars I'm gonna go get me a four thousand
dollar car and put it down here in the
driveway or I'm gonna Uber somewhere and
I'm gonna Uber I'm not renting anymore
I'm gonna quit we are not going out to
eat and hey uh chick you need to get a
job or you need to move out because I'm
getting rid of this two thousand four
hundred dollar apartment for two broke
people if you don't and oh by the way
I'm getting out of this New York leash
for sure and we're gonna run a cheap
stinking Hotel over across the river and
haul your little butt over the Staten
Island Ferry over there and get to work
and you know you don't have to spend
that kind of money to work in New York
um because you got to change some stuff
man that that if I'm you that's what I'm
doing but you got you got to turn this
disgust into Behavior change the shame
in the behavior change